hello we're glad you joined it for this
webinar improving the fill mix
performance a view through a local lens
I am Michelle Ashton of lab herbs and
I'll be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
levers leading scientific social
networking websites and provider of
virtual them webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and sponsored
by Agilent learn more about our sponsor
faces at WWll calm let's get started you
can post questions to the speaker during
the presentation while they're fresh in
your mind to do so simply type them into
the drop down box located on the far
left of your screen labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
questions will be answered after the
presentation via email to enlarge the
slide window click on the arrows at the
top right hand corner of the
presentation window if you experience
technical problems being a violent at
presentation just click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by typing it into the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
I now face Bruce crystals the associate
professor at Brigham Women's Hospital in
Boston Massachusetts to learn more about
our speaker please visit the speaker tab
at the top of the presentation window
first will now begin his presentation
all right I'd like to thank you today
for listening to a presentation on
improving lipid omics performance and a
view through a local lens I'll start
with my disclosure there's no specific
issues that are scientifically related
to what I'm going to talk about I have
in the past license 10 patents to
metabolize all of metabolomics I have
consulted for them in the past
I hold non-public equity and I do get
post sales royalty everything of which
was through a prior university and I
have known other talk relevant
affiliations in the last 5 years
I want to start with this and this is
really the central message that I want
to talk about which is that lipid omics
technology is a lipid omics platform
it's not simply one component of the
system for example the mass spec but
it's everything put together in
particular in the context of what I'm
going to talk about is the Triad between
the biological system the analytical
system and the data analysis system now
in today's talk I'm going to focus
really on only on the analytical
chemistry side and I'm going to talk
about it conceptually I'm not a mass
spec person I'm not a chemist I'm a
biologist but what you got what I want
to get across are the conceptual
advantage advances that have been made
and how these move the field forward and
again I want to talk about the fact that
this is a view through a local lens and
what I mean by that is this is a
convenient sample these are a set of
experiments a set of papers that come
out of my lab over roughly the last
seven or eight years and they are
therefore convenient for me to talk
about but it goes beyond that so first
of all these are the papers I'll refer
to them throughout the talk you'll have
a list of all be highlighted where it's
relevant but the key point here is that
this is conceptually biased by my
interests these advances these papers
these studies were all based around the
fact that we're trying to answer
questions in biology and by no means
should you think that we're the only lab
that has advanced lipid omics or by any
stretch of the imagination that I think
that that really what you're looking at
are the changes that we've made to solve
problems and you could take multiple
other lipid labs across the world that
have done similar things they've for
example increased quantitative accuracy
where they've increased precision or
they've increased the ability to see
certain lipids or to see those lipids
faster or more sensitive in all cases
they're solving problems and it's
important when you're looking at lipid
omics particularly when you're looking
at lipid omics and
a field or a lipid omics paper or a
lipid omec study to realize that in a
lot of cases you're solving specific
problems and another way of saying this
is that lipid omics is by no means a
fully mature field it's not a single
assay it's not really a set of assets
okay it's a lot more than what often
gets viewed from the outside that it's
simply a matter of how cheaply you can
do it or how fast you can do it now
there are cases where cost is the
dominant factor or where speed is the
dominant factor but there are also cases
where it's depth of search that's
accurate or making sure you don't have
false positives or don't have false
identifications and so again it's a fit
for purpose assay and it's really
important to keep that in mind
analytical chemistry is not a science
that surprisingly gets lost and taken
for granted in a lot of the discussions
I see in conversations for example with
clinicians or with biologists who lose
the fact that this is a rapidly evolving
scientific field and arguably moving it
forward in many ways is still an art as
we don't know exactly the best way to
improve what we're looking at so our
central question for well over 20 years
now has been a metabolic stereotype of
diet lifestyle and environment in other
words developing a way to look at a
person's blood or other biological
fluids and identify markers for disease
risk not so much for Diagnostics but can
we figure out what disease these person
is at risk for and you can conceptually
embed this in the concept of how do we
study complex biological or clinical
research problems or you could say it a
different way how do we address such
questions in humans where our ability to
manipulate and analyze the system is
very limited and that goes back to this
triad you have to think about the
biological systems that enable you to
address this study you have to think
about the analytical systems that will
enable you to get the data that you want
and the data analysis approaches the
informatics
purchased it will give you the insights
you're looking for in our case where
we're looking at a very large product
project and we're looking at a project
with very low signal to noise and we're
looking at by definition subclinical
phenotypes we don't know what we need we
need to profile targeted methods are not
going to help us so breadth of coverages
for example very important for us you
can again conceptualize what we do in
this type of a diagram and what you're
looking at on the leftmost side is
sample collection okay or at the bottom
the outcome you want mechanistic insight
you want drug development insight or
classification and prediction in our
case um you may want to do functional
genomics how we linked phenotype to the
genome or as I said sub-threshold
studies this is the biological aspect
sample collection the choice of an
analytical platform and the biological
questions being asked analytically you
have to worry about sample collection
how do you need to do sample collection
to get the studies you want again what's
the analytical platform and exactly how
that analytical platform is developed
and then you need to do the data
reduction that's an analytical chemistry
problem to decide what data should be in
that database then you have a data
analysis component it begins with
understanding the analytical chemistry
platform you have to know what your
platform doesn't doesn't do and doesn't
and doesn't do Wells strongly um you
have to clean up that data you have to
understand how that cleanup works and
what its strengths and weaknesses are
then you have to choose the appropriate
bioinformatics tools so if we now switch
we focus on lipids you can broadly break
lipids into eight classes the fatty
acids of fatty acids themselves the
glycerol lipids the glycerophospholipids
the sphingolipids the sterols the
parentals
the poly key tides and the Sakura lipids
in our case where we started this with
an involvement in questions along
mitochondria lipids my
unreal biology and we started by
building off a platform that had
originally been developed by hanka Meyer
it uses a high resolution high mass spec
on platform and again I'm not an
analytical chemist I won't go into the
details of what I'm talking about if you
want the details go to the papers
because the papers will have those
details but basically we run both a
negative and a positive ion
it's an electrospray instrument and
we're looking at the fatty acyl the lie
so glycerophospholipids the
glycerophospholipids the cardia lie
ppens the sphingolipids including the
ganglia sides we're looking again in the
positive ion mode the lights of
phospholipids the glycerol lipids
including the mono die and tri acyl
glycerides the acyl carnitine is the
sphingolipids swing of my owns and the
ceramides the parentals and we get a lot
of information if for example we get
over a hundred phospho colons out of the
mitochondria we get over sixty
phosphoethanolamine zout of the
mitochondria 31 phosphoglycerate so on
all the way down a lot of ceramides a
lot of triacylglycerols that are the
structural lipids in the mitochondrial
membrane sorry the the trace or glycerol
we get a lot of ceramides we get the
string of islands we get the ganglia
sides
and we get the triacylglycerols within
the mitochondrial fraction the
glycerophospholipids the mono ISA bliss
rolls the dice of glycerols the fossil
Coleen's the plasminogen phospho
Coleen's the lights of phosphor Coleen's
the phosphoethanolamine x' the
plasminogen phosphoethanolamine x' the
light so phosphoethanolamine
phosphoglyceraldehyde acetal x' and the
cardio light but at the time the
platform was developed we can see a
lipid that's present at a couple of
lipids per hundred thousand with about a
5% cv add a lipid that's presence
roughly at one lipid in 10,000 pieces
mass accuracy is about 2 ppm and in this
untargeted method we can already pick up
more cardio Lightman's than we see in
the targeted method so in essence what
this is doing is it's turning the non
targeted method into a semi targeted
method in other words it's blurring the
lines between the non targeted and the
semi targeted method and again if we go
back we can take this same platform and
we can now apply it to a tribe listened
to a certain pool and now we see that
serum triglycerides and these are
basically the first two papers published
and I'll point out that these two papers
were first also with Susan Berg who did
about a lot of the analytical chemistry
in the lipids and Lam the other person
does a lot of it is ROS kathan gu and
they were the two people who ran the
lipids platform in my lab during the
time of this but then I want to switch
gears and I want to talk about
biologically what we were doing and here
in this study we were focused on looking
at the interaction between mitochondria
macronutrients and the blood tab along
I'll stress here was the blood
metabolomic but what I want to talk
about is about bottlenecks in leverage
and the ability of a lipid omics
platform to get you through these when
we started this if you look at this
interaction figure very little was known
about the interaction between diet and
mitochondria but a tremendous
- mount was known about the other
interactions within this figure so we
hypothesized the diet associated effects
on mitochondria are linked to diet
associated changes in disease risk
now point out this was a very complex
study it was looking at developing
biomarkers out of serum it was looking
at developing target validation it was
looking at biomarker outcome validation
and the study itself was fairly complex
we had a 24 dietary group study in
animals the animals were fed ad libitum
for eight weeks we then had were
measuring food consumption and growth in
the animals we had multiple practical
functional assays in the mitochondria
all of which were then taken in through
our scripts for the informatics and we
had a lot of biochemistry that was
planned particularly on the stored
plasma samples when we did the study
however and this is a mitochondrial
functional study where the upper left is
looking at in essence the idling state
of the mitochondria the upper right at
the functional energy production state
the lower left at the ability to switch
between these states and the lower right
at the ability to couple these states
tightly without losing energy or
generating free radicals there are well
over 16,000 comparisons in this slide
and we had less than chance that were
statistically significant so we were
really at a major bottleneck because
this was in essence how the entire grant
was designed this is a gigantic
bottleneck and because of this we switch
to start to offer what we added in was a
mitochondrial lipids component and if
you go back to this triad we have the
rats the biological system the
biological questions of mitochondrial
function for example we added a lipid
omics component and we added some via
data analysis and what this does is it
allows us to leverage what we're doing
so we now add in biochemical
mitochondrial targets which were not
originally a plan and we start with the
idea of looking at cardio cardio life
ins about 20% of the phospholipids in
the mitochondria they function as a
proton trap they're essential for
mitochondrial structure they're
essential for mitochondrial enzymatic
activity when you have mitochondrial
dysfunction their concentration
decreases the ezel chain composition
changes and there's oxidation and I'll
point out that this is arguably the
central loop of energy metabolism
okay there's one other lipid that could
compete for this and we'll come back to
that a little bit later but we see 28
structural variants in the cardio
Lightman's and as I pointed out earlier
at the time this was done that was more
than was seen by targeted methods we had
developed an informatics platform which
enabled us to in essence reduce any
given lipid into a series of 14 pages
worth of informatics and they could be
scanned quickly and what you see on one
of the cardio light bones is two of the
diet's have vastly altered levels that's
the dark squares in the upper left and
when you look at this on a dot blot on
the upper right you see that these are
actually saturated fat and trans fat fed
with high glycemic index so in other
words cardio - is actually increased in
the bad diets and it's increased a lot
but
strikingly what's more or less known in
mitochondria is that cardiolipin never
goes up okay so this is some sort of
compensation effects never really been
seen but then the question becomes
what's driving that
well we profiled so even though we had
no intention of doing it
we now said what could cause this well
the obvious thing to look at is the
other major lipid which is the
ubiquinone so these are the parental
lipids coenzyme Q or the ubiquinone and
there are three major ones in rat liver
mitochondria for all practical purposes
the major one is coenzyme q 9 it sits
within the electron transport chain it's
the dominant electron transport lipid
within the mitochondria of rats in
humans the dominant is Co Q 10 but Co Q
9 goes down what's striking there is
that ubiquinone x' never go down in the
literature without drastic losses of
mitochondrial function and as I showed
you earlier there are no changes so
what's going on can we look at oxygen a
lipid component
and ideally we want something that might
accumulate and again we can take
advantage of the fact that we profile so
we can back and look for things that we
never thought of in particular we look
at what are called mono lie so cardio
type ins these are cardio life ins that
only have three fatty acyl chains and
that could be because one has been
damaged and knocked off or could be
during the synthesis phase of the cardio
items and we're fortunate that we see
two of them they are minimally abundant
that presents at a couple of copies per
hundred thousand lipids and strikingly
they are also increased in these two
diets so yes we can see something that
might be accumulating can we look at
something that might be much more
clearly oxidative stress than derived
and what had been shown by another group
was that eighteen 118 one lipids undergo
sis trans isomerisation in the presence
of file radicals okay so for example if
you look at the fist trans lipids okay
what you're seeing is normally you have
a cyst shape and it makes the membranes
more fluid okay but when you oxidize
them you hit them with a file radical
and they undergo a set of reactions they
now give you a trans lipid and these
trans lipids turn out to be separable in
our system on a series of c18 columns
and in fact we can detect these two
molecules differently in a pooled
mitochondrial sample and this method is
entirely been published and what we see
is again the cardio Lightman's
are this um this trans isomerisation is
increased in the case where you have
these elevated cardio Lightman's and we
believe you have our evidence of us in
stress we now can go back again because
we profiled and we can look at the
entire cardio - pool cardio weapons
typically are believed to be on the
backbone and for 18 - s we do know that
there's some variation in this
when we look at the variation in fact we
see that there are enormous changes that
we see for example this one lipid is
extremely elevated in animals fed
saturated fat diets okay so there's a
level of regulation that really wasn't
anticipated when we look at this in more
detail if you just focus on the bottom
center panel what you see is that the
predicted based solely on fatty acids
randomly shuffled and reassigned per
muted four of one of them has a much
lower level than what's calculated so
the observed is the top the calc as the
bottom that's the red arrow and ten of
them actually have higher in some cases
much much higher levels than would be
anticipated so there's both positive and
negative selection for which variants of
cardio life and get kept into the system
this to some extent this overall study
has altered the concept of ubiquinol
respiration regulation and evidence for
as many as five new levels of cardio
life and regulation and again this part
of the talk is about bottlenecks and
leverage you see what these more
advanced lipid omics techniques allow
you to do it took about a week of mass
spec time it bypassed the bottleneck it
quadruples the actionable information
from 1.7 million dollar study and it
allowed us to leverage all the other
data for this and again all these work
has been published so let's switch now
from the mitochondrial side of this to a
completely different matrix so we
started to look at fecal lipid omics in
particular we did it because it offers a
biological and analytical advantage for
the study of neonatal GI disease we know
that lipids are central to intestinal
biology they're more stable too many
metabolites and they're more conserved
than proteins the use of fecal matter
has huge advantages in the sense that is
a completely non-invasive approach that
doesn't deplete the premature infants of
it's limited blood volume
so you get the same basic system except
you've replaced those top panels with
the infant fecal lipid extraction and a
different analytical platform and what
we focused on was method development we
start with a pooled sample we look at a
dilution series we look at different
extraction buffers and we looked at it
with and without the presence of
pressure
overall it's a 60 sample study and we
see that as we spaced out across the
chromatography you see first of all
different lipids that are better
extracted in mbte versus dichloromethane
we see lipids that are better seen in
the absence of pressure we see ones in a
second I'll show you that are better
with pressure and we see the analytical
criteria we see whether or not we're
getting a three to one difference in
dilution so we can see how effective the
delusions are and what we see and this
is obviously in a lot more detail in the
paper is that everything makes a
difference in some cases the delusions
do not work you can have far too much
you can you can have too much material
for the extraction buffers in some cases
pressure helps in some cases pressure
appears to create artifacts you get more
lipids with some scenarios you get less
lipids with some scenarios sometimes you
get more lipids but they're more error
prone so again this becomes a very fit
for purpose type of analytical system
but it allows you to look at this
biological system and ask questions that
are that are going to be relevant and
again this work has been published now
what I'd like to do is to switch systems
again to talk about a study that we did
ancillary to the calorie trial so the
aim of the lipids component of this was
to develop optimize and validate a
defined series of nested plasma lipid
omics based biomarker profiles and it
builds off work that we had done in the
rats looking at rat markers for caloric
restriction and we have in time we did
this an app analysis the first time we
had 504 structures identify
plasma lipids about 200 almost 200 of
them were tries to glycerols almost a
hundred of them with phosphor coins and
what we see in this particular case
looking at the triglycerides was that we
really didn't see separation based on
resting metabolic rate resting on total
energy expenditure or looking at the
groups in other words
adlib versus CR as they were defined in
the trial we didn't see it males we
didn't see it in females was very
negative result but we know in the rats
that even a 10% CR and the female arm
brown Norway rat um I will point out for
site before I forget this isn't this
entire study is not published although
it's all been presented multiple times
so you would expect to see this so in
the humans in contrast we seem to see
minimal effects or nonspecific not
specifically more specifically nothing
really replicates compared to what we
would have expected for the rats and to
a certain level this defies what we
would think of as common knowledge we
know that people who lose weight tend to
have lower triglyceride levels and we
don't see that okay so even though we
didn't get to 25% which is what the
trial had hoped to do the 10% or 11% of
12% should have been more than enough to
see this kind of effect so maybe it's
just a triglyceride effect and in fact
we tested this and this is not true so
one of the things we looked at was
what's called hotbox it's a commonly
used method where one heats an arm
before a blood draw it's used for
different things in particular in this
particular case it was used for
catecholamine draws it was used as the
baseline as part of the baseline 12
months and 24 month work um those were
the first tubes drawn we got one shortly
after it and we wondered if this could
make it a mistake could be causing
issues it didn't have an effect at the
population level there were no obvious
increases or decreases in triglycerides
but maybe there's some sort of pooling
issue
when we looked at the energy lipid
associations at zero 12 and 24 verse 6
and 18 we see that those relationships
are really no longer related so the pink
home message here is that sample
collection matters in really unexpected
ways heparin if heparin eyes tubes are
allowed to sit around for a long time
you see an alteration of lipids as a
lipase activity and so this needs to be
considered when you're dealing with
sample collection as again as a fit for
purpose aspect so now I'd like to to
change gears again and talk about
reducing Mis annotations so we were
originally part of a ring trial in
lipids and when we started to do some of
that work we got a couple of results
that didn't make sense to us so we
stepped back for a little bit to figure
out what was going on and what Rose
kasanga who is the lead on this showed
eventually was that if you have for
example ISO phosphocholine
you can get in source fragmentation so
this is fragmentation within the
electrospray source that actually leads
to biologically valid in other words
biologically real lipids that weren't in
the initial sample or were at different
levels of the initial sample in the
particular case shown the fragment
source fragmentation of a lie so
phosphocholine 16o can give you a life
of phosphoethanolamine 18o and a fatty
acid 16o by taking advantage of the
chromatography and again the fact this
is a profiling method we can see that
the fatty acid 18:1 runs in two places
if we look at a distracted eye in
chromatogram one of them in fact the
dominant one is actually a fragment of
the LPC's it's not a real free fatty
acids row we rose determine that you can
see this in multiple cases for instance
from the LPC's you can see it from the
LTE's you can see from the PCs you can
see if the Swingle nylons
um and when we actually looked focusing
in this particular slide on the data
that is actually in the NIST dataset and
we worked with John Boden and Jeremy
Cole mellowness what you see is that
about ten of the lysa
phosphoethanolamine are potentially
fragments they're potentially not real
in the database and what was done in
silico was to basically determine all of
the cases where this can occur and to
make that available as a dataset and
again this is all published finally I
want to turn to improving identification
so we talked about reducing Mis
annotations misidentifications one of
the issues is improving fossil Sirian
detection so saw so serine is a little
bit harder to detect it also is
typically lower abundance and biological
systems and ROS took advantage of the
fact that deuterium labels fossil
collates so if you look at the Internet
of the left and right arm lipids here
the fossil choline is on the left the
phospho serine is on the right they have
the same mass but if you expose them to
deterioration exchange to occur you get
the deuterated salt of the fossil : when
you now run this if you start in the
normal buffers you have two lipids with
identical masses and identical from
isotope patterns that are
indistinguishable whereas if you add the
deuterium you can now see that it's the
lipid that's running in this case 1321
that's the fossil calling and again this
method has been published
so what are the challenges going forward
if you go back to the global question
biologically what are the design
questions valid controls statistical
power hypotheses are determining what
the conf owns our sample collection
getting matched samples analytical
issues I'll come back to in a second
biological issues such as maximally
appropriate coverage for the problems of
interest IDs dealing with flux if you
need to deal with appropriate conditions
under the biological systems determining
whether or not things are robust across
time with inter class correlation
coefficients in getting a robust data
collection and analysis at the
informatics level statistics versus
informatics multiple comparison problem
building robust models on establishing
models a litter date if we go back to
the analytical piece lipids is by no
means a single assay it's by no means a
set set of assays okay there's a lot to
still be developed there's a lot to be
gained by tailoring the platform to the
problems of interest there's issues
about sensitivity there's issues about
specificity these issues as I showed you
about both increasing correct IDs and
decreasing false IDs there's critical
questions about improving the linear
quantitation range about improving the
breadth of coverage reducing the
coefficients of variation identifying
double bonds identifying cysts trans
bonds identify an oxidative coverage
it's a wide open area that still needs
development
acknowledgement Susan burden Rosa
Thunder did the vast majority of the
analytical chemistry Fatima Cousy was in
a lab for a little while did some of it
Irina Stavros kaya was the dominant
biologist in my laboratory for over 15
years she's now in Colombia all of the
mitochondrial work you saw was her a lot
of the animal work you saw was her mask
niat in ski in the summer or the -
informatics people have been with me for
over ten years John Bowden and Jeremy
Cole Mel who are NIST when this was done
Pamela start reading Van Hubbard were
biological collaborators that were @ih
Kate Gregory's a PhD nurse originally at
BC now at the Brigham who ran the all
the neonatal work and who conceived a
lot of neonatal work with Alan Walker
who's at MGH Alex Lazaro of your gross
were at a company that we collaborated
with some of the pressure studies Pablo
Lara and Heather Greenberg were Tech's
who did a lot of work in these projects
and at various points these studies have
been funded by ni a
NCI NHLBI ni EHS NIDDK and NIGMS and I
thank you very much for your time and
I'll be happy to take questions by email
thank you
Thank You Bruce for your presentation a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of the presentation window
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button
Bruce will answer your questions via
email after the presentation we would
like to thank our educational sponsor
Agilent for today's educational webcast
laberd's will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye